we do have arena with us Arena welcome
back to the show yesterday when you came
here and you said you're fighting for
the podium but more importantly you're
just feeling good about yourself your
friendships that you have been
developing and it definitely showed in
this game this was not an easy task with
the white piece sure it's a player that
you have been enjoying uh success
against but she was on a te and you
stopped her tell us a bit about that
yeah um I felt like this game was was
really quite good um from the beginning
like there were a few things that I did
that I was quite happy with um in the
opening when I played this 95 move um
stopping her E5 plans and then I played
Bishop B3 and neither of those moves
were obvious at all yeah like they kind
of took me a lot of time and I mean
certainly 95 like you can try to play
that position in a much more standard
way but 95 I was like you know I can
actually fight against the E5 idea and
Bishop B3 also like very you know
prophylactic because the ideas every
time she takes on E5 she's not going to
get B5 with Tempo I'm going to threaten
Knight E4 so I was really quite happy
with this oh and the other point to
Bishop B3 is that if she takes on D4 and
I take on D4 she doesn't have Knight B6
right and sort of like yeah um this type
of idea yeah so she's not going to hit
the bishop and the pawn um at the same
time so those things like were actually
really important to me building up this
game and obviously you know at some
point I had just like a most wonderful
position I also think like the plan of
uh you know doubling on D file while of
course you know everyone knows Rooks
should come to the open file it wasn't
completely obvious to me in the game
just because there are so many other
opportunities to plan the king side um
but yeah once I got to this position I
knew I was doing well um and of course I
had you know very uh very poor technique
in in winning this position so you know
um what you saw was not very clean at
all because once I took the pawn in age
six it must have been completely
winning and unfortunately we have some
problems with the board we will Rectify
that in just a second maybe you can take
it from here yes yeah just go go through
where you felt um it was great Queen
takes H6 you're a happy
camper and then what happened I mean mhm
well okay maybe maybe starting from here
I just I I kind of Wonder right because
Queen D Queen H3 seems so obvious but
then she got her Queen out because I
couldn't take with the Rook because of
Knight E2 and once the queen came out I
actually she realized it was not easy so
it was really just like in some very
short amount of time I wonder if maybe
even Queen H3 was a mistake maybe I
should have played Queen H4 that way I
can take with a rook on D3 um actually
yeah Queen H4 yeah why not I mean um it
makes a big difference yeah right and
then she can never really trade because
the rook's coming to H3 was kind of
unpleasant so I mean something like this
should have been should have been
convincing right but I really I just
thought my position was so winning I
kind of didn't feel that she could come
back into the game but once Queen H6
happened I knew she was back in and I
saw this Knight B5 C4 idea so you know
really kind of losing control but not
completely at this stage as we're
getting into the first time
trouble um obviously you know I thought
this position was stable for me after B3
like I you know it seems very
unfortunate to let the black pawn get to
C3 but um you know I'm kind of holding
everything with my control of the
defile um
and okay here feeling sort of okay about
how things were going still had to make
the time control um Queen F3 I don't
know if that was a good decision or not
it was seems okay uh to go for this end
game and basically here I was at least
feeling pretty safe about my position
like I knew this Pawn was not going to
promote and I thought there were de
decent chances to win this end game and
of course the really interesting moment
happened you know a few few moves later
and here I I feel like maybe I messed up
up right um so I was looking at you know
Knight C3 was sort of my main
calculation after Rook B8 Rook
D4 um I can show you uh yeah Rook D4 if
Knight C3 then I was going to take on C2
and allow Knight D5 and play e takes D5
uh Rook takes C2 and D6 and I thought
that this should be a winning position
for
me um it is it is Rook to B2 D7 and you
get the win
but she found this I kind of missed
night 283 and that shocked us as well
because it doesn't seem like you have a
way to make any progress in the position
and in fact this was a critical moment
because you allowed a three-fold
repetition and in fact know she did not
stop the clock and she played this move
Knight to A3 this would have been the
third time and at this point with only a
few seconds on the clock you made that
decision to continue the game you could
have played King E3 that's going to be a
draw you made a decision continue the
game with F5 what was going through your
mind at that point you know I had
finally seen this idea of F5 right
because my whole attention had been on
the queen side when I realized like I
just couldn't win the game on the queen
side def despite the fact that all my
pieces were there um all the action
would seem to be on the queen side and I
couldn't win so that was really uh quite
quite disappointing for me that this you
know King D3 idea just doesn't work um
and then finally you know and I'm
running down on the
you know I kind of saw F5 I was like oh
actually I'm not just giving away a pawn
because she gets M it if she takes it so
this is like some sort of possibility
for me to you know play uh you know
maybe get rid of one of the double pawns
so I had seen this idea but I needed the
king I guess I needed the King on like
in this position this is where I wanted
to do it and you know you know when
you're down to 5 Seconds like I knew I I
was allowing the repetition but at the
same time I already had seen this idea
and I was like once she didn't take it I
was like okay and now I'm going for it
and I was really happy that I I found
this because obviously I didn't really
want the draw you know it was more a
situation of just like running down on
the clock and you know making sure you
don't lose on time which I could easily
do as I'm sure you guys you know know
know so um you know F5 was yeah probably
my best moments of the game because you
know you're already sort of supposed to
be acquiescing to the three move
repetition you got no time compared to
your opponent but you know you pull out
that little bit inside of you to play
for the win and um you know that's kind
of in my opinion the best moment of the
game for me absolutely and it definitely
paid off congratulations Arena big
victory for you and you're throwing the
gauntlet in this tournament because the
standings once again changed
congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you Christian absolutely
our congratulations